your doctor will perform a dilation and
curettage also known as a DNC to remove
tissue from the inside of your uterus
the uterus is a muscular reproductive
organ in your lower abdomen the lower
part of the uterus called the cervix
connects the vagina to the uterus a
diagnostic DNC may be performed to
investigate the cause of the following
conditions abnormal or heavy bleeding
severe menstrual pain difficulty
becoming pregnant or abnormal cells
found in a pap smear a therapeutic DNC
may be performed to treat certain
uterine conditions such as excessive
bleeding after birth from remnants of
the placenta cervical or uterine polyps
fibroid tumors which are benign tumors
formed on the uterine wall and
incomplete miscarriage or abortion in
which parts of the embryo or fetus or
associated tissues remain in the uterus
your doctor may want to begin the
dilation process the day before your
procedure if so your doctor will place a
softening medication or a thin rod
called a laminaria into your cervix the
laminaria slowly expands by absorbing
fluid from your cervix causing your
cervix to open
during the procedure you will lie on
your back with your legs placed in
stirrups as you would for a standard
pelvic exam you will receive local or
general anesthesia
your doctor will insert a speculum into
your vagina which widens the vaginal
canal so the cervix can be seen
during dilation your doctor will insert
a series of smooth rods into the
cervical opening each rod will be
replaced with a slightly thicker rod
there by slowly widening or dilating the
cervical opening so the inside of the
uterus can be accessed once the cervix
has been expanded to about six to nine
millimeters your doctor may perform a
hysteroscopy a procedure in which a
small light and camera are used to
examine the inside of the uterus for
abnormal areas
next your doctor will perform curettage
which is the surgical removal of part or
all of the uterine lining called the
endometrium
during curettage a surgical tool called
a curette will be inserted to remove
tissue by scraping or suction
if you are having a diagnostic DNC your
doctor will remove only a small sample
of the endometrium and send it to a lab
to test for various conditions if you
are having a therapeutic DNC your doctor
will remove the entire contents of the
uterus to treat a known uterine
condition
after the procedure you will be
monitored in the recovery room for a few
hours before you can go home to prevent
infection do not have sexual intercourse
or use tampons for about two weeks or
until your doctor says it is safe to do
so since your uterus will need to
generate a new lining your next
menstrual period may not occur at the
regular time